hello everybody my name is susannah
kimurahara i'm an assistant professor at
the department of chemistry at the
university of calgary i would like to
thank everybody for coming today to my
presentation
today i will be talking about a novel
analytical method for the quantification
of disinfection byproducts at trace
levels in recycled wastewaters
but first i would like to acknowledge
the students and staff that worked on
this project
in this case alejandro ortega hernandez
rafaela caballa chad verwell and jill
murakami
so water disinfection is the worldwide
com worldwide commonly used practice
that inactivate pathogens and provide
safe drinking water
common commonly used disinfectants
include free chlorine
combine chlorine or chloramines
ozone and chlorine dioxide
ever since the first continuous
chlorination of municipal water was
was used in 1908 in jersey jersey city
i'm sorry a steady decline of water
waterborne diseases such as typhoid
fever and cholera has been observed
and so by the 1940s the vast majority of
water supplies in developed countries
had complete treatment
and were considered microbiologically
safe and so in this graph we have the
death rate
for 100 000 population due to infectious
diseases on the y-axis
and over the years from 1900 to 2000
and as you can observe there has been
there has been a steady decline
due to chlorination and other medical
breakthroughs
this reminds us of the importance of
water disinfection and a common practice
that is currently being used today
however these chemical disinfectants may
react with natural organic matter and
other ions that are natural occurring
in in river and lake waters
um and so these chemical disinfectants
react with these uh these other
compounds to unintentionally form
disinfection byproducts
to date there's more than 700 dbps or
disinfection byproducts that have
already been identified and some of them
pose a health risk as indicated
by some epidemiological studies
certain chemicals
third chemical disinfectants can promote
the formation of different disinfection
by-products
currently the u.s and canada have
maximum contaminant levels
for several disinfection byproducts
including
methane and hal acetic acids which are
predominantly formed by
uh
chlorine disinfection
bromate which is predominantly formed by
ozone disinfection
and chloride which is probably formed by
chlorine dioxide
while
while only certain states in the united
states have guidelines for
nitroso-dimethylamine or ndma
it is ndma is not currently regulated in
the us however in canada ndma has the
maximum concentration
guidelines
of 40 nanograms per liter
so as you can see in this table there's
uh different disinfectants on the
left-hand side
and they can form different regulated
and non-regulated disinfection
byproducts so some of them i already
mentioned
uh chlorine predominantly formed
telescope hello trial of methane and how
acidic acids
uh combine chlorine um
forms ndma but it's not currently
regulated in the u.s
but there's a guideline in canada and
chlorine dioxide and ozone form chloride
and bromate as mentioned
however there is
these disinfectants can also form
other other types of disinfection bypass
for example combined chlorine can
perform can promote
chromatochlorine can promote
the formation of nitrogen containing
compounds including
ndma or nitrosamines senogen highlights
heliceda nitrils and halocenamides
other classes of concern are iodinated
disinfection byproducts including iodo
trihalomethanes and iodo acids
so why are we concerned with this
unregulated disinfection byproducts
dr pelowa from the university of
illinois in urbana champaign has tested
more than 100 disinfection byproducts
with one single bioassay
what this allows is that we can directly
compare the toxicity of different
disinfection byproducts
and so in this graph as you can see you
have the different disinfection by
product chemical classes
we have the regulated the five
palestinic acids that are regulated
as well as the non-regulated
nitrogen-containing non-regulated
disinfection byproducts
and so in this graph it shows that
it compares it directly compares the
cyto and genotoxicity
of of these compounds cyto cytotoxicity
means
the concentration of a compound that
produces cell death in chinese hamster
ovary cells in this case
and genotoxicity is the concentration of
a compound that produces tma damage
and so the larger the graft the
larger the bar graph the more toxic it
is
and so in this in vitro studies they
shown that the non-regulated helices
nitrile amides and nitromethanes are
more cyto and genotoxic that are
currently regulated
another thing that they found was that
the brominated and iodinated dbps are
more toxic than the chlorinated
disinfection byproducts
additionally but what does it mean
for human health
so
anaphyla epidemiologic study found a
higher increase
a higher increased risk in the incidence
of bladder cancer
with the consumption of chlorinated
surface water
there's an another study that has also
found associations between disinfection
byproducts and adverse reproductive
outcomes including low birth weight and
preterm delivery
and so although there are risks to
long-term exposure of disinfection by
products the whole reason and what we
must remember is that we apply water
disinfection
to protect human
population from an acute risk of
pathogens that produces uh waterborne
diseases
so even though there's chronic risk we
must remind ourselves of the key risk
and um
that we don't want to
um catch
for waterborne diseases
so with an evolving environment uh
however with an involving environment
that is an increase in population
climate change and as well as older
infrastructure
for wastewater facilities
these can lead to higher amounts of
compounds into legs and rivers that are
human-made or man-made
and so
so one example is
wastewater treated wastewater they're
being introduced into
uh lakes and rivers that are then used
later on for
um for drinking water purposes and this
we call de facto wastewater we use so de
facto wastewater reuse
is the unintentional use of wastewater
to drinking water sources for example
in this graph we can observe the city
one obtains their source waters from a
reservoir that's fed by snow packs and
glaciers
in the mountains they're they're coming
down the mountain similar to
the city i currently live in calgary
calgary then use this as water and then
produces wastewater which is treated and
then returned to the river
this river will then flow to city 3
and
city 3 then uses water from that
particular
river for drinking water therefore
there's a percentage
of that river
um
that is treated that has treated
wastewater and we know this as a de
facto wastewater reuse is it an
unintentional use of wastewater
and so there was a study done in the usa
in 25 cities
and over a 30-year period of time so 17
of those 25 cities
had an increase de facto reuse about 68
percent
the four largest cities have a de facto
reuse about eight percent or higher that
means that eight percent
of their drinking water source comes
from wastewater inputs
furthermore there's been also wastewater
spills across
developed countries
including canada so
for for example in november 2015 there
was about five billion
liters
of raw sewage that was introduced to the
to the san lorenzo river in quebec
um
and so but
this de facto uh
wastewater reuse is not only an issue
that
um
pertains to developed countries but also
developing worlds or more so it's more
it's more severe in in developing worlds
countries like mexico and brazil have a
high de facto uh wastewater reuse
because they have poor sanitation
and so
in this slide
it's another it's a review
it's a review that um
compiles the maximum concentration
quantified in treated drinking waters in
brazil
and so what they found is different uh
emerging contaminants the highest one
are disinfection byproducts which is um
um
which which which is it should which is
um expected however uh they also found
uh caffeine
about 5.8 micrograms per liter
and also
they also found basil lecomi
which is the main metabolite of cocaine
at about 652 nanograms per liter
so this is telling us uh because it has
caffeine and metabolites in the drinking
water
that there's a significant um
good factor
wastewater reuse that um is coming into
the direction into the drinking water
and so
so now if we have
these uh wastewater impacted waters that
are less pristine than before
and it has more human-made contaminants
and we apply disinfectants um
as well as uh advanced treatment if it's
uh something for
main
if it's if it's waters that we want to
treat uh for portable reuse
so
this this can produce a plethora of
other chemicals so then there's some
questions that come up so
what kind of compounds are being formed
in this in this water with these new
man-made uh chemicals
are there new disinfection byproducts
being formed
and are the water quality guidelines uh
adequate for reused water so for example
we looked at the diff the different um
disinfection byproducts are being
regulated but are those
the same with changing water
so we don't know this and so this is
um
so this is uh
one of the reasons and one of the things
that my research our my research group
are interested is to look into
um the kind of of compounds that are
being formed with
reused waters
and so
in order to do this we have to develop
highly sensitive analytical methods that
could look at
disinfection byproducts at low
especially since emerging contaminants
are typically
found in in low nanogram per liter so we
needed to
um
develop these high highly sensitive
analytical methods and so we developed a
method of 25 priority dvps with the with
a ptv gc tandem aspect
instrument and ptv is a programmable
temperature inlet
followed by gc 10 and mass spec
and so these 25 priority dvps include uh
halo 7 nitron so again
there's a cyanogen
um functional group attached to this
compound tri iodo trihalomethane so
there's an iodide in in one of these
x's
halo nitromethanes
trihaloaldehydes and haloketenes
the other thing that we found
challenging with these that are
challenging with these compounds is that
they're light sensitive and also
unstable or they can be very reactive
and so uh
we developed uh
uh this 25 priority dvps with
a gc tandem mass spec
and then this was followed by an
improved liquid liquid extraction
and then we evaluated the the
this analytical method
for matrix effects especially with
secondary uh treated effort as well as
the overall performance of the
analytical method
and so the first thing that we we had to
select were the mass spec transitions so
for each gdp uh there was a precursor
ions that were selected
based on the on the base peak that means
the most abundant ions
however the precursor ion for a few dvps
were selected on the second stronger
second second strongest peak
and the reason was because three
hello ketones had um abate the a base
peak of 43.1
and so
if we if we um
so this would produce a very low product
ions so we cannot quantify at such a low
mass to um to iron ratio
we also found uh
two
a similar issue with two iodinated
trihalomethanes where the base peak led
to really poor uh product irons
especially because these compounds are
really really small
i think the largest would be about 250
dolphins and so
some of these we we have to choose the
second strongest peak in this case the
iodine trihalomethanes we have to choose
the molecular
the molecular ion
then after we we chose the cms
transitions we
uh continued to do a collision energy
optimization so first the we started
with halocentral nitriles they were
manually optimized by incrementing the
collision energy applied to each
precursor ion
the collision energy was optimized once
the maximum abundance was observed for
the quantifier and qualifier transitions
as shown in this figure
once we did this manual we compared it
to the automatic
wizard that is available in the
instrument and we found very similar
values so then we went ahead and did an
automated
collision energy optimization for the
rest of the disinfection byproducts
the next step in the gc
msms method were the time segments and
time segments and dwell time so we
introduced four time segments
and these time segments limits the
number of chemical transitions
to scan
per segment
this time segments ensure a higher
sensitivity of the triple quad by
reducing the number of chemical
transitions to scan per for each segment
after we chose the time segments we um
we went ahead and determined the dwell
times and this refers to the sampling or
scanning time spent for each peak during
the
multiple reaction monitoring
typically longer dwell signs result in a
higher number of ion hits to the
detector
resulting in increased sensitivity of
the analyte and also the peak shape is
dependent on these 12 times as seen as
an equation below so we determine the
dwell time based on the pick width
uh divided by the number of of total
transitions per segment times 15. 15 is
uh that's the number of points we wanted
to
uh have across a peak
and so uh with this we had a really nice
separation of of all of the 25
disinfection byproducts
the red arrows signal the different time
segments and we had a really nice peak
shape
as well for for these disinfection
byproducts
so after um
determining the mass back parameters we
went ahead and and improved the liquid
liquid extraction method
um we started with an existing method
that uses a hundred
milliliters of sample
uh with this three times extraction of
five mils for a total of 15 milliliters
of organic solvent
and then it's blowed down uh to about
200
microliters
and so
we then come reduce the the sample
volume to 50.
and as you can see from the graph these
are just two
dbp chemical classes there's a
significant reduction in percent
recovery
um so we then um
went ahead and reduced the final
extraction volume to increase to to
concentrate the analytes in the final
extract
and we did see a slightly higher
recovery than experiment
two
however handling
um
the the handling upon of blowing down to
100 microliters
was
a little bit challenging so we decided
to to go back and and try to
we to um use the final extract about 200
microliters
and so for the last experiment instead
of 50 we went to uh 10 milliliters
with an organic solvent about
nine milliliters total with three times
extractions of of three milliliters for
a final extract volume of 200 and we
observed a
similar or higher
percent recovery for some disinfection
byproducts we did observe a percent
recovery that were lower for another
ones however it seemed that experiment
four provides us with the the most um
optimum value for most uh disinfection
byproducts and so we went ahead and used
uh 10 milliliters to 200 microliters so
this what this meant is um
we reduced the concentration factor from
500 to 50.
um and this is also very important
because we we're we're looking at these
analytes in wastewater ethylene so
the less uh
sample that we extract we could also um
reduce
the extraction of other compounds that
are found in secondary wastewater
essence
and so we also did
an optimization of the shake time so we
shaved
10 milliliters in triplicate
um with spiked uh analytes for 5 10 and
15 minutes and we did not observe
significant changes uh
with the shake time so
we
we decided to use uh five minutes
and so um we tested the methods
performance um and compare it again with
a hundred with the original liquid
liquid extraction so we added um 100
nanograms per liter spot a spike of the
different disinfection byproduct
standards and ultra pure water and
compared it to 10 milliliters and we
observed
there was a
very slight uh changes in some cases
there it was an increase of percent
recovery from 31 to 142 percent uh we
also observed that we we obtained
um relative standard deviations less
than 10 for the spike recovery
and we also went ahead and and did an
instrument position study with um
with seven replicas at three different
um concentration levels and we observed
a relative standard deviation of less
than three percent except uh for
trichloroacetin nitrile
so yeah uh
so in also in the percent recovery we
did observe a slightly lower
um
uh
percent recovery for trichlorocele
nitriles however
um this has been reported in other
methods and it's just it seems that it's
a a trouble uh compound for most
extraction methods
um
and so um
so this is uh the previous study that we
compared so these are the method
detection limits from a previous study
um as well as our current study
and so the method detection limits
for
for our method was between 2 and 68.9
nanograms per liter so
um
and so this is compared to another
method that used 100 ml of sample with a
concentration of 500 times and they use
the single quad instrument in order to
um analyze this disinfection by product
so this shows that uh the method that we
developed was was able to
quantify disinfection by products at
nanograms per liter or low of ppt levels
in uh secondary wastewater f1
and then uh
we also tested the matrix effects so
this was a five micrograms per liter
spike
in pure water and we did the same for
secondary wastewater effluent
and we saw the percent recovery just
slightly lower
for secondary wastewater effluent um so
this was comparable with pure water
the other thing as even though we were
quantifying percent recoveries
are
the calibration curves are are made from
spiking into ultra pure water and then
extracting them
and so even though we do have these low
uh percep recoveries for example for
tri-chloroacetone
it still quantifies the quant the amount
that we spiked it because
um we we use spiked
samples as our calibration standards
so once we develop this method and
validated
uh for dbps and secondary wastewater
reference so we tested the method in a
full-scale research facility here in
calgary alberta named aqua or advancing
canadian wastewater acids
so this is a
a secondary uh wastewater it's a
wastewater treatment plant that treats
uh wastewater uh to um
uh to produce secondary effluent and
then this is uh then pulled or
transferred to at the research facility
which
consists of a microfiltration unit
uh of of three membrane units of ran in
parallel
and then uh they're treated either
through reverse osmosis or ozone
oxidation
and so what we wanted to observe
is the efficacy of these
advanced treatments
of of micro filtration reverse osmosis
and and ozone oxidation
to remove
the precursors to disinfection
byproducts and what i mean by precursors
are
the things that the species react with
in order to form the disinfection
byproducts if we remove
those uh compounds or those precursors
then we're going to produce less
disinfection byproducts
and so the way that we did this is
through
doing
formation potential testing with uniform
formation conditions
and so we obtained samples uh from each
uh
treatment
and we dose them with either chlorine or
or chloramines or in this case
monochloramine so we dose them and
incubate them for about 24 hours
at 20 degrees celsius at a ph of eight
after those 24 hours
we stop the reaction of of the chlorine
disinfectant with ascorbic acid
and then we extracted right after with
the liquid liquid extraction and
followed by the gc tandem method method
that we analyzed so we developed them
sorry
and so these are so i'm going to show
you in the next few slides is the dbps
that we quantify before and after
disinfection so in this graph as you can
see
uh these are the
disinfection byproducts quantified in
the water samples with no disinfection
so here you could see that
that halo set are nitrile and and
and then iota methane were quantified in
the wastewater ethylene
um however they were reduced
uh they were reduced
in the uf treatment in the
microfiltration treatment
however
uh something that we did notice is that
there was two new compounds that
appeared in the microfiltration in this
case chlorosodine nitrile and
dichloronitromethane that were not in
the effluent and i think we believe is
because the microfiltration units are
cleaned every two weeks with a highly
concentrated chlorine
disinfectant and we believe that they
tend to leech out over time so we
probably observe some of these compounds
forming uh
from the microfiltration unit itself
then uh as the uf ozone treatment what
we observe is that
we primarily form halo7 nitrile so this
is about 100 nanograms per liter or 0.1
micrograms
and this is primarily because of
dichloro acetonitrile
um and also um
we we observe
um
yeah so this is
so
they and and so this what we observe
this enhanced formation of
dichlorostatic natural is not something
that was observed in other full-scale
portable reuse facilities
um and so it seems that the household
nitrile formation could be unique to the
composition of the ethylene organic
matter here in in calgary so this this
is something that has not been observed
before
and then also after
uh
uf treatment we did see um
other disinfection by-products including
halocentral nitriles hello nitromethane
but the highest one was iota thms
and
there were studies that have looked at
this and they found that
these uh compounds the dichlorostatic
nitrile
dichloronitromethane and iot agents are
typically not well rejected by ro
membranes and they tend to appear after
reverse osmosis treatment
so we want so those were the target dbps
that we quantified but we also wanted to
know what other
organic halogen
compounds were contained in these com in
these waters and so we also analyze it
with a total organic halogen method that
can quantify any organic molecule that
has a halogen attached to it
and so we do observe
that these numbers are much higher so
previously there were
in in the low uh
nano in the low nanogram per liter
levels but these are on uh micrograms
per liter
level so we do see
with this non-target analysis that the
organic
chlorine was significantly high
in the effluent in microfiltration so
about 100 to 122 micrograms per liter
but this is then reduced at the ozone
level after ozone treatment i'm sorry
um and then it is further reduced with
after ro so
ozone and ro removed about 65 to 85
percent of the total organic chlorine
however uh we could see that total
organic bromine and total organic iodine
i were some more or less consistent
uh total organic bromine were between
we're about six micrograms per liter as
bromide and
total organic iodine was between
three and
nine micrograms per liter of iodide so
um there seems to be
some some of these uh brominated
iodinated pvps
in these processes however the ufro
completely eliminated the
organic bromine and organic iodine
from these waters
so then we
we analyzed the dvps that are formed
after adding chlorine to each
each uh
water sample and so here we could see
we have the
effluent and then effluent with chlorine
so we could see that these
disinfection byproducts are formed after
you add chlorine and we observe that we
have a high formation of halocena
primarily halocena nitriles so this is
almost 18 micrograms per liter of
helicity nitrile
this is
composed primarily again by
dichlorostatic nitrile
and bromochlorocytonitrile
the other thing that we noticed is that
the effluent
and uf
samples have very similar
results and we believe is because uh
before we chlorinated
we um we filtered the samples with the
with with a membrane filter and so we
believe that we we might have filter out
things from the effluent and so after we
chlorinate it we we observe similar
formation of disinfection byproducts
that's why um
in in most of us in most of our slides
you're going to see that the effluent
and the uf samples after after
disinfection are going to have very
similar
results
and so
and so after that uh we also observe um
a halo set of nitriles as a predominant
uh dbp class uh due to again
dichlorostatic nitrile
but we also observe
um hello uh nitro methanes as well
so um and this is um
and so uh we so after ozonation we
observe that uh ozonated reduced the
halocenter nitriles by 42 percent and
this has been uh corroborated by other
studies as well that they observe um a
lower formation of halocene and nitriles
after
um
after ozonation followed by uh
uh free chlorine
um and then for the last uh section we
the last example the ufro treated sample
we do see a formation of halo nitro
methane um
we we see we first observe a significant
reduction of overall all the
disinfection byproducts
um and i think we believe that this is
due to the removal of the organic
carbon content
from ro it removes about 85 percent and
so
if there's less precursors you're going
to see less disinfection
byproducts as well however again we we
do observe in within these chemical
classes we do observe um
nitromethane
in this case dichloronitromethane and
bromochlor nitromethane
um
and um and and a few helices one heliced
and nitrile and and and iodo thm
and so um
okay
and so for the next slide
uh we did the similar
uh disinfection experiments but in this
case with combined chlorine or
monochloramine
and
first of all what we
what i want to highlight is the the the
y-axis so it's not
and so for free chlorine we produce
about a total of 18 micrograms per liter
so
combine chlorine we see a less
formation of disinfection byproducts
so um we see about eight micrograms per
liter in total
for the secondary effluents and you have
treated waters
um
we they exhibit similar uh speciation
trends um however
um
so we we see the hello central nitriles
and the similar um disinfection
byproducts have been formed uh the the
one that we did notice uh and we do not
notice with free chlorine is the
formation of halo ketones so we didn't
observe hello ketones with free chlorine
but we did observe them with
monochloramine so that was an
interesting trend uh that we observed
with these ones
and so contrary to free chlorine when
the chlorine ozonated you have ozonated
monochlorinated water produce the
highest disinfection byproducts
from
um
in in these experiments
um this result suggests the ozonation
increases the precursors that lead to a
higher disinfection by product formation
so in the previous one it eliminated if
you use free chlorine but in this case
it it it increased the formation of the
precursors that led to these
disinfection byproducts
um
and so the highest uh
uh this the highest dbp class includes
hello nitro methane
uh followed by halo ketones and
halogen uh iodo thms and halocena
nitriles
and so
if we compare
the halocena nitriles between the uf
and ozone and as before
ozone
and uh after ozonation we see an
increase
a small increase of household helocated
nitrile formation and this is
not usual or observed in other studies
however
there was one particular study that
observed the higher formation of
halocenting nitriles due to
higher concentrations of bromide in the
water
and so we did measure the bromide in the
water and we had about 40 micrograms per
liter of bromide which led to the
increased formation of a brominated of
bromochloroacetin nitrile and therefore
we see this slight increase of halo
halocene nitrile
the other thing that we i wanted to
really notice is um the formation of
iota thm so iot hms
there was none before before ozone and
then we see them after ozonation
um
it seems that um
these these what that ozone produce four
times more itams
um in chloraminated than in chlorinated
waters
um
furthermore it's it's significantly
higher
um and so we we
we also tested for iodide in the waters
and we didn't find uh
we didn't find iodide in the waters so
what we suspect um is that the iodide
that produces this ith hm comes from the
total organic iodine
so when i show you the the previous
graph of what's contained in the
wastewater we did see about
four
40 ppv of total organic iodine and so we
believe that ozonation
could have
break down these compounds
and after
chloramination
form this iodinated thms especially we
we see a high concentration of
of
iota form in in this in these waters
and finally similar to other samples uh
the arrow treated waters are the ones
that has the least amount of
of dvps um from all the classes formed
iota chms was the largest dep
and this was attributed to dichlorido
methane there was a few others that were
also detected in these waters
okay and so
we did also
have some preliminary data by season so
the data i showed you was was from fall
of 2019
and uh we did sample back in the summer
initially
and as well as in the winter
but then due to pandemic we were able to
to sample uh further however we did see
different trends by season um i'm not
going to go in detail to to
to all of them but what i just want to
highlight a few of them so
you observe that dichlorosedan nitrile
seems to be
a
dbp that comes up in most of all all of
the samples
as well as bromochloroacetonitrile
dichloromethane was observed in fall in
winter but it not in summer
and uh the very interesting is that we
see these hello ketones only forming in
winter for um for hocl uh
treated
waters and so um
for for
chloraminated water we we also see
dichlorostatic nitrile form in most of
in all of the waters throughout the
different processes
as well as dichloro nitromethane
we did see a significant amount
after ozonation in fall and winter we
did not observe this in the summer we're
not sure exactly why
but we need to further investigate this
we did observe
hello ketones
in in the fall in the summer but we did
not observe them in the winter
and iota thms are are present um
in all of the waters and so this is just
preliminary data but uh i have a new
student that's coming um from overseas
that's going to continue this work and
also expand it into characterizing
your the organic matter or the compounds
that are contained within these samples
before they disinfect to see what kind
of precursors are
are
are
forming these disinfection byproducts
it says conclusion um
so hello set of naturals dichlorostatic
nitric oil was the largest forming
palutena nitrile in both disinfection
methods
um bromochlorous that are natural only
form and fall in winter
and also preozonation followed by
chloramine
increased the halocentral nitrile
formation especially the brominated
species possibly due to high bromide
levels
um dichloro nitromethane was the largest
forming hello nitromethane in both
treated waters
dichloronitromethane formed at similar
levels regardless if it was treated with
chlorine or
combined chlorine
how hello natural methane is largely
formed and
uf ozonated effluents
as well as ro chlorinated waters
for halo ketones
we observe that
1-1 dichloropropanone
mainly formed in winter with chlorinated
waters
um and also it was formed in the summer
and fall with uh
um chloraminated water so we the hello
ketones tend to appear not appear in
different depending on which samples we
treat them
um also uh the one one
trichloropropanone and one three
dichloropropanone
uh also form significantly in winter
only so
the holoketones appear in some cases and
sometimes it doesn't
um and so for the iodo th hm the lowest
uh forming group with free chlorine
it was a form
had a high formation with a cool
chloramine
i'm sorry to combine chlorine
particularly with ozone
uh combine chlorine and oroco my
chlorine
and organic iodine precursors seem to
promote the formation of iodo thms
and so with that i would like to
acknowledge uh the different partners
and and that uh supported this research
and as well as uh my research group
here at calgary
thank you and now i can take any
questions